when I heard that Richard Gere was not
nominated for his great performance in
Chicago I said to myself welcome to my
world Richard Gere and now the awards
that are very dear to my heart
the Writers Awards finally the studios
are getting much more respectful of
writers I handed in the script last year
and the studio didn't change one word
the word they didn't change was on page
87
our next presenter won an Academy Award
for her role as the painter Lee Krasner
in the movie Pollock here is Marcia Gay
Harden
this award is about screenwriters one of
the on-going debates amongst them is
whether it is more difficult to create
an original screenplay or an adaptation
of previously written material say from
a book a play or a musical some who have
done both say the most difficult tasks
these days is simply getting the job to
write anything at all and here are the
writers nominated for adapted screenplay
Peter hedges Chris Weitz and Paul Weitz
for about a boy based on the book by
Nick Hornby Charlie Kaufman and Donald
Kaufmann for adaptation based on the
book The Orchid Thief by Susan Orlean
Bill Condon for Chicago based on the
play by Maureen Dallas Watkins David
Hare for the hours based on the novel by
Michael Cunningham
Ronald Harwood for the pianist based on
the book by vladislav Spellman and the
Oscar goes to
Ron Harwood for the pianist
first Academy Award and second
nomination for honored
he was nominated for an Oscar in 1983
for the dresser
when I was last year 20 years ago I'm
not making a habit or a dumb way Shirley
MacLaine got Best Actress and when she
got the statue she said I deserve this
well I wish I could say that but I can't
roman polanski deserves this
visa he's a great director and a
wonderful colleague and I want to thank
him and of course you for this splendid
honor thank you very much indeed